[Musique]
je n'appelle daphné dix ans j'ai 12 ans
je suis jeune joueuse de niveau
provincial
je pratique la gymnastique dès l'âge de
5 ans le juge se fait nommer
j'adore bouger les abeilles ont une
importance particulière sur notre
environnement sans elle robin ne serait
plus la main et si moi vous dire
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
sans abeilles la vie s'arrête
savez vous que depuis plus de 30 ans la
population des abeilles diminue de
manière catastrophique
c'est ainsi que maintenant rendus sur la
liste des espèces en voie de disparition
les habits sont d'une très grande
utilité pour notre société
elle ne cherche pas juste un piquet pour
nous déranger non elles font ceci juste
part ils se sentent en danger
nous n'en avons vraiment besoin et nous
devons agir
les abeilles meurent à cause des
pesticides et insecticides et les
herbicides et cetera des produits
phytosanitaires utilisés dans le domaine
de l'agriculture
les produits phytosanitaires cl du
produit que l'on met sur les végétaux ou
qu'elles ne se fassent pas mangé par des
instincts
ces produits sont très violents et c'est
ce qui cause la mort de nombreuses
années plusieurs mesures ont été mises
en place pour empêcher l'utilisation de
ces produits
malheureusement beaucoup d'agriculteurs
continue de les utiliser aussi de
nouvelles substances nuisibles prennent
le relais comme la pollution de l'air et
le changement climatique la
déforestation et cetera
en plus plusieurs maladies maladies et
parasites entre en jeu cousant la mort
d'une tonne d'abeilles maintenant je
vais vous en apprendre un peu plus
social si les habits à dessau
pratiquement tous les continents de
notre planète à l'exception de
l'antarctique
elles font partie de la grande classe
insightec et plus précisément de leur
des hyménoptères il ya plus de vingt
mille excuses d'abeilles partout à
travers le monde dont la plus connue
la fille mellifera ou la dernière
l'essai qui produit la série et le miel
quitte les et humain depuis des milliers
dans la vie et le prince par un steak
pollinisateurs et joue un rôle de
premier plan dans les écosystèmes
d'entre eux précieux planète en
permettant aux végétaux de se multiplier
saviez vous que toutes les espèces pour
de différentes formes d'organisation
sociale
la petite alimentaire et d'activité
comme par exemple certainement aucun
d'or d'autres sont répétitifs et
d'autres manches charbon par contre et
surtout de mes plans morphologie elles
ont une taille un tract et un abdomen
quelque chose que je trouve très
impressionnant si c'est ainsi qu'il va
4400 fois des ailes chaque minute soit
240 fois chaque seconde
si pour c'est que l'on entend un petit
bourg de ma copine à des approches la
menace des colonies d'abeilles sauvages
et domestiques disparaissent depuis
plusieurs décennies
ce phénomène se nomme le syndrome que
l'effondrement des colonies d'abeilles
les productions apicoles en sont
grandement perturbé les autres
l'importance d'avoir du miel pour notre
propre plaisir si c'est un fake venait à
disparaître
cela causerait l'extinction de 80% des
espèces végétales
or sans végétaux les animaux ne pourrait
se nourrir et les conséquences seraient
aussi dramatique pour le en +35 centre
ressource alimentaire mondiale dépendent
de la pollinisation des abeilles dont
plus des légumes plus de fruits ainsi
que plus d'autres produits albert
einstein disait même et si l'abeille
venait à disparaître l'humanité on
aurait pu encore seulement quatre ans
quelques petits gestes que vous pourriez
faire pour leur venir en aide il y en a
tout plein aujourd'hui je veux faire
part de quelques uns de ceux ci
premièrement vous puis répandre la
menace qui pèse sur ses seins c'est
comme cela votre entourage sera plus
informés et la fera plus attention vous
pourriez également planté un jardin ou
des fleurs ou encore acheter des
produits biologiques
car les personnes qui produisent ces
aliments n'utilise pas de produits
phytosanitaires
vous pourriez également construire un
hôtel à 1,7
un goûter à 1,6 à 100 a assuré les
pollinisateurs quelques missions tout
petit
bush et bordant les abeilles ces
insectes vous donnons un coup de pouce
pour votre jardin en échange d'une
chambre où passer la nuit
comme dernier petit geste vous pourriez
laisser au bout de votre terrain en
friche
cela veut dire qu'à cet endroit couper
le gazon rarement ou pas du tout cela
permettrait aux fleurs sauvages de son
pari de ce petit bout de terrain et
elles vous aideront à améliorer la
biodiversité de votre jardin
pour finir les abeilles court un grand
danger une aussi si nous ne réussissons
pas à stopper la disparition de celle-ci
n'oubliez pas il joue un très grand rôle
dans notre société
elle ne cherche pas jusqu'à nous
déranger cette leur attention
merci
[Applaudissements]